[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
méduse le monstre dans toute sa
splendeur terrifiante ancien beauté
sublime transformé par vengeance en
vision d'horreur chevelure brillante de
certains et surtout un regard qui
pétrifie celui qui le croisent mais ai
je vraiment besoin de vous la présenter
chacun ici ne l'at il pas déjà
rencontrés sous une forme ou une autre
car en fait méduse est partout en nous
autour de nous elle est la peur la
souffrance le mal-être la maladie les
nôtres celles du monde lui résister
c'est véritablement mener un combat
or ce combat n'est pas à armes égales
car si nous regardons méduses en face
nous sommes pétrifiée comme tous ceux
qui ont cherché à l'attaqué en direct
car son pouvoir et tout puissant
donc c'est aussi nous voulons attaquer
méduses
que faire tout ce qui fait mal et bien
plus grand et plus fort que nous cela
nous fragilise et peut même nous a menés
jusqu'à la nuit l'aliénation
bien souvent nous n'avons pas la force
d'agir et nous laissons agir par tous
ceux qui cherchent à nous contrôler de
l'extérieur comme par ceux qui a déjà
pris le pouvoir à l'intérieur de nouveau
et le pire c'est lorsque nous ne nous en
vendons même plus coûte alors le combat
est il pour autant perdu d'avancé
et bien c'est sans compter sur
l'existence d'une ruse assez
extraordinaire la stratégie du détour
l'exemple nous en est donnée par percer
versez le héros grec s'est donné pour
mission de tuer la gorgone méduse est de
ramener sa tête
comment s'y prend t-il percée sait très
bien qu'il ne pourra combattre seul le
monstre aussi va-t-il faire appel à de
l'aide extérieure en la personne
d'athéna athéna la très rusé déesse de
la guerre et de la justice athena sera
présente au combat mais elle n'y
participe qu indirectement son aide
viendra d'un outil très précieux
l'un de ses principaux attributs son
bouclier d'argent
ce bouclier est tellement poli qu'il
peut servir de miroir alors athéna va
placer ce bouclier d'argent entre percé
méduses pendant le combat
de telle sorte que d'une part percée
puisse combattre sans avoir besoin de
regarder son ennemi en face et que
d'autre part méduses se pétrifie
elle-même en découvrant son propre
reflet dans le bouclier est ainsi percé
peu la décapiter sans danger ce bouclier
d'argent aura donc constitué l'élément
stratégique de détournement permettant à
percer de sortir vainqueur pour résumer
nous avons donc quatre acteurs en
présence pendant ce combat il y à un
héros perd c'est un monstre ennemis la
gorgone méduse une présence amie athéna
et quatrièmement le personnage principal
le bouclier d'argent
symbole de la stratégie du détour
alors en quoi ce mythe de persée peut-il
nous servir aujourd'hui c'est qu'il est
en tout point transposable au domaine de
l'art thérapie ce sont exactement les
mêmes acteurs en présence
il y à un héros le héros c'est vous ici
présent c'est chacun d'entre vous en
toute singularité c'est deuxièmement le
monstre est ni le monstre ennemis et
bien c'est le monde mal portants c'est
ce qui fait peur ce qui fait mal ce qui
rend malade que cela vienne de
l'extérieur ou de l'intérieur
mais c'est aussi troisièmement une
présence à nice c'est votre compagnon de
voyage
l'art thérapeute et quatrièmement bien
l'outil druzes ce fameux bouclier
d'argent qui est ici personnifié par ce
que nous appellerons le processus de
création artistique
alors je vais vous proposer une petite
expérience et vous demander de fermer
les yeux fermés tous les yeux s'il vous
plaît pendant quelques instants et
laissez vous guider par ma voix je vais
moi aussi fermé les yeux
fermons donc tous les yeux et je vous
invite à imaginer le lieu de l'action
vous êtes dans un atelier d'artiste
essayez de vous imprégner de
l'atmosphère de ce lieu
en observant tout ce qui s'y trouve les
objets les outils les peaux les tubes
les pinceaux les couleurs les coulures
sur les murs les tâches sur les chiffons
essayez aussi de vous imprégner d odeur
si particulière dans un atelier
d'artiste la colle l'huile de lin la
térébenthine la poussière aussi imaginer
une autre personne est présente avec
vous dans cet atelier c'est votre
compagnon de voyage
l'art thérapeute elle a fixé au mur une
grande feuille de papier blanc est posé
sur une table une assiette emplie de
peinture noire et elle vous tend un
pinceau un très beau pinceau gros et
touffu et vous invite à vous en saisir
pour poser sur la feuille de papier les
traces comme ça vient
alors vous vous mettez en mouvement vous
vous saisissez du pinceau et vous allez
vous placez devant la feuille
avant de démarrer vous êtes invités à
poser votre main libre sur la surface de
la feuille pour en sentir l'eau grain
essayez aussi de vous imprégner de la
blancheur du papier de son éclat comme
si vous vouliez rentrer à l'intérieur et
puis vous allez simplement tendre le
bras qui tient le pinceau et appuyer le
pinceau sur la feuille et déjà une
première forme apparaît ou tout au moins
une première trace
et puis vous continuez vous élargissez
un peu votre geste en étirant vers la
droite vers la gauche vers le haut vers
là-bas comme vers le bas vers comme ça
vient
l'important pendant que vous tracez et
d'essayer d'observer comment votre trace
suit le mouvement de votre bras essayez
aussi de sentir comment votre pinceau
glisse sur la feuille et de ressentir la
douceur et l'onctuosité de la peinture
qui se répandent peu à peu sur votre sur
votre trace sur votre feuille et c'est
ainsi que déjà vous voyez apparaître une
première forme sur la feuille et puis
vous allez revenir vers votre assiette
pour recharger votre pinceau avec la
peinture etc le moment très important
dans le processus pour pour patrouiller
pour tout y est dans la matière
pour s'en imprégner et alors pendant que
vous faites ça que vous rechargez votre
pinceau essayer simplement d'observer la
fluidité la souplesse l'onctuosité la la
viscosité aussi de votre matière observé
la profondeur du noir son velouté et
puis lorsque le pinceau et suffisamment
rechargé vous allez vous placer à
nouveau devant la feuille et poursuivre
comme ça vient
les traces préalablement commencer
surtout ne réfléchissez pas laisser vous
simplement guider par votre main et par
votre bras délesté tout délester vous de
toute intention particulière et c'est
ainsi que petit à petit vous allez voir
apparaître des petits détails des
symboles des signes peut-être étrange et
puis garder toujours les yeux fermés un
on n'a pas tout à fait fini et puis vous
allez reposer votre pinceau et vous
reculer légèrement pour observer avec
une petite distance votre production
observée
regardez comment est organisé l'espace
de votre feuille observer vos lignes les
droites les courbes
comment elles se croisent pas rendre par
endroits et comment elle s'écarte à
d'autres observez vos traits pleins ceux
qui se vident observé aussi vos
épaisseur et les coups de brosse plus
faim observée chaque détail car c'est là
que tout se joue dans l'observation la
plus minutieuse du détail et ses détails
se révéleront précieux par la suite
et puis tranquillement je vais vous
inviter à revenir
ici et maintenant tous ensemble dans
notre belle salle du grand théâtre de
limoges et de rouvrir les yeux pour la
suite de la présentation en art thérapie
il y a quatre 4 éléments qui vont
constituer ce donc que ce mouvement
inédit de résistance c'est premièrement
la première trace que vous avez posé
tout à l'heure celle qui est venue de
façon spontanée qui a jailli de vos
mains c'est deuxièmement ce que nous
avons fait tout de suite après c'est son
observation minutieuse
troisièmement consécutivement
c'est le ressenti intérieur associés à
cette observation se ressentit doit être
au plus profond de soi au plus près de
soi et c'est ensuite
quatrièmement la trace suivante le coup
de brosse le coup de pinceau suivre la
production suivante l'oeuvre suivante
et tout ça va s'inscrire dans un
processus donc c'est ainsi de suite
ainsi de suite ainsi de suite et c'est
ainsi que vous entrez dans un mouvement
inédit celui du processus de création
ce processus c'est une médiation entre
vous et le monde
c'est lui le bouclier d'athéna
c'est lui la stratégie du détour car
comme vous vous en êtes rendu compte
pendant la petite expérience
il n'y a pas de message direct on ne
regarde pas méduses en face il n'ya pas
d'expressions intentionnelle pour dire
par exemple je suis triste où je peins
mon cancer eh bien non lahrissi
s'intéresse non pas au fond mais à la
faune
exclusivement à la forme et au cours de
ce processus les formes que vous aurez
créé vont prendre de plus en plus de
complexité vont devenir plus techniques
vont aussi devenir plus présente pour
vous est plus importante
et ses formes eh bien elles prennent
racine dans la reconnaissance par vous
même de certains détails de ces petits
signes de ces petits symboles dont je
vous parlais tout à l'heure
et ces petits signes ces symboles ces
détails sont essentielles car c'est eux
qui vous permettent de vous mettre en
contact avec vos images référentiel les
plus profondément ancrée celles qui
permettent de se dire ils permettent de
se dire en toute singularité et au bout
d'un temps qui peut-être mon plus ou
moins eh bien ces formes que vous avez
créés vont finir par avoir leur
existence propre
en se détachant de vous mêmes en voûte
dépassons c'est la situation que connaît
chaque artiste
lorsqu'il doit bien reconnaître qu'il a
été dépassé par son oeuvre il s'est
passé quelque chose de mystérieux qu'il
n'a pas maîtrisé et c'est à ce moment là
seulement que vous aurez sans même vous
en rendre compte
créez vos propres outils de résistance
car voyez vous créez en art c'est
recréer le monde à son image à nulle
autre pareille
et c'est là toute la puissance du
travail de l'art thérapie qui contient
intrinsèquement la possibilité de
changer le monde
c'est comme si on voulait dire j'agis
sur le monde
en me laissant agir par la forme
symbolique qui a jailli de mes mains
résister
passerait ainsi par l'invisible de la
métaphore contenus dans la forme
artistique est censé dans cet invisible
que pourrait se situer sa puissance ce
qui permet à chacun quel qu'il soit bien
ou mal portants de se recréer en
devenant son propre artistes advenir de
la sorte à soi même c'est se mettre en
résistance active et illimité face à
tous ceux qui nous brise nous aliène
nous enchaîne on cherche à nous
contrôler cela renvoie également chacun
d'entre nous au questionnement
fondamental qu'est sa place de créateurs
dans la société car créer c'est
véritablement résister merci
[Applaudissements]